hey guys welcome back to another live
session by simply learn
i am kirtana and in today's session we
are going to talk about
how to become a data scientist in 2021
now there are a lot of aspiring data
scientists out there
so i'm sure this video will help you all
out
but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our channel
and hit the bell icon to never miss an
update
we come up with interesting videos every
week
so i see a few people joining in let's
wait for some more time for more people
to join in
i also like to welcome all the viewers
joining us from facebook
now i see a lot of people have tuned in
if you have any doubts acquiries
feel free to leave a comment in the chat
box we have a dedicated team here who
will help you solve your queries
let's begin our session now so for the
ones who've joined in now
today's topic of discussion is how to
become a data scientist
in 2021 so here are the topics we'll be
discussing today
a brief introduction to data science
laying the groundwork for a data science
career
a short note on who is a data scientist
later we'll discuss the in-demand
technical skills for data scientists
and then the salary of data scientists
after which we'll discuss the future of
data science
and data scientists so now
let's have a brief introduction to the
field of data science
there is no specific definition to
describe data science
if you ask 500 people to describe what
data science
is you'll probably end up getting 500
different responses
because data science is a continually
evolving field
well under wikipedia data science is an
interdisciplinary discipline
using computational methods processes
algorithms and systems to derive
information
and insights from both structural and
unstructured data in simple terms
data science is the domain of study that
deals with
vast volumes of data using modern tools
and techniques
these tools and techniques are used to
find unseen patterns
derive meaningful information and make
business decisions
the data used for analysis can be from
multiple sources
and present in various formats
there is a saying a jack of all traits
and a master of none
when it comes to being a data scientist
you need to be a bit like this
but perhaps a better saying would be a
jack of all trades and a master of
some let's now discuss about laying the
groundwork for a data science career
let's now look at some of the
prerequisites for getting a data science
job
have a relevant degree a solid
educational background
is required to be a data scientist
pursue an undergraduate degree in data
science
or any closely related fields like
statistics
computer science or mathematics after
the undergraduate course
a master's degree in one of the relevant
areas
is an added advantage creativity
and critical thinking creativity in data
science is very much needed in this
field
you will need it for creating a
storyline for innovative modeling
for developing new tools different ways
to collect your data
and lots more parallely critical
thinking is very useful in data science
a data scientist should be able to
develop questions
and at the same time question the data
as well
require technical and non-technical
skills
we'll be discussing in depth the
required technical skills
later on in this video talking about the
other necessary skills in this field
you will need problem solving skills
risk analysis
and many more good communication skills
having a strong command over your
communication skills is very much needed
in this field
the outcomes that are delivered through
data science
are quite complicated and hard to
explain
you will have to translate your
technical findings
clearly and fluently to the other teams
you will need good presentation skills
storytelling skills
writing skills and listening skills
in short make sure you focus on building
lasting relationships through your
communication
here are some of the roles in the field
of data science
data scientist machine learning engineer
machine learning scientist data engineer
data analyst statistician
business intelligence developer
infrastructure
architect enterprise architect
applications architect data scientist is
most likely one of the most
sizzling job titles among the lot and
now
let's talk about who is a data scientist
in simple terms a data scientist is the
one
who practices the art of data science
a data scientist analyzes business data
to extract meaningful insights in other
words
a data scientist solves business
problems through various methods
dj patil and jeff hammerbacker coined
the term data scientist
a data scientists work typically
revolves around data
and his role will be a combination of
three main subjects
computer science statistics and
mathematics
it's time to discuss the in-demand
technical skills for data scientists
to become a data scientist you need
various skills as mentioned earlier
some of the significant technical skills
you will need to master include
programming there are several
programming languages for data
scientists
learning and mastering at least one of
them is
essential to realize various functions
of data science
but at the same time just a single
language
can't solve problems in all areas
python is the most widely used
programming language in the world today
when it comes to data science the next
widely used language is r there are
still some data scientists who use
r instead of python but if you're doing
applied data science these days then
you've got to learn python because
that's the most
valuable programming language for data
scientists
some other languages include javascript
scala sql etc
talking about python programming
language it is
open source and easy to use language
you will need to understand the basic
syntax of this language initially
you will need to know how to write
functions loops
and modules you should be familiar with
both object
oriented and functional programming in
python
it is a general purpose and dynamic
programming language
that supports multiple paradigms one of
the factors that make python stand
out from the rest is its flexibility
you can use python for almost all the
steps involved in data science
the next skill we'll be talking about is
machine
learning the concept of machine learning
has been around for a while now however
the ability to automatically and quickly
apply mathematical calculations
to big data is now gaining a bit of
momentum
you will need to learn techniques such
as supervised machine learning
decision trees logistic regression
and natural language processing one of
the crucial reasons why you need machine
learning in data science
is because of the high value predictions
that can guide better decisions
and smart actions in real time without
human
intervention there are in fact a lot of
advantages of machine learning in data
science
it helps analyze large chunks of data
and it changes the way data extraction
and
interpretation works to sum it up
machine learning and data science can
work hand in hand
with machine learning being such a craze
data scientists need to learn it this is
why
simply learn has introduced a
revolutionary machine learning
certification program
that provides advanced level training on
the applications
and algorithms it uses we have provided
the link in the description box for the
same
do not forget to check that out here's
to yet another essential skill in data
science
math mathematics is the bedrock of
any contemporary discipline in science
it's one of the major requirements for
data science
some of the major math topics you will
need to know are
calculus linear algebra probability
and statistics some other math topics
that will help you solve data science
problems
are discrete math graph theory
information theory and many more
up next we have analytical tools
they help you extract useful meaningful
insights from data and provide you with
valuable frameworks
for processing big data data analysis
is a core practice of modern day
businesses and choosing the right
analytical tools is very challenging
as no tool fits every need anyway
some of the most used analytical tools
in data science are sql
spark hadoop hive and many more
coming to data visualization it is an
interdisciplinary field that deals with
the graphic representation
of data data visualization plays
two prominent roles communicating
results clearly to a general audience
and organizing a view of data that
suggests
a new hypothesis of the next step in a
project
some of the data visualization tools are
matplotlib
ggplot and d3.js
data visualization encompasses
techniques that are used to communicate
data
or information by encoding it as visual
objects that are contained in graphics
well as big data keeps growing data
visualization becomes an
increasingly crucial tool
up next we have data of wrangling this
is the process of gathering selecting
and transforming
data to answer an analytical question
it will help the data scientists fast in
decision making
and hence get better insights in less
time
data wrangling is also known as data
cleaning
or munching at last we have
business acumen when you are a data
scientist
you must have more business sense in
analyzing the data
in other words you need to know whether
the insights gained from the data
is of value to the business or not hence
business acumen plays a very vital role
in structuring
business data analytics when we are
talking about business knowledge
three things come into the picture
general business knowledge
industry specific knowledge and company
specific knowledge
knowing these are very much important
when you are a data scientist
so guys this sums up the end demand
technical skills for data scientists
well
let's now discuss the salary of data
scientists
before we go into the topic we would
like to introduce our new platform skill
up
where you can find some of our best
courses for free we are offering more
than 1 000 hearts of content for free
which can help you acquire more than 300
skills
across a number of different categories
take the next step to grow in your
career by joining skill
by checking out the link in the
description
when we are talking about the salary of
data scientists
many factors come into the picture the
salary would depend on the experience
he or she holds the industry
the company size educational background
and finally the region according to
glassdoor
the average salary of a data scientist
in india
is close to 10 lakh rupees and that in
the united states
is close to 1 lakh 13
309 dollars in the i.t
field the driving factor behind high
data science salaries
is that the companies and organizations
are realizing the power of big data
and they want to use it to drive smart
business decisions
coming to our last topic of today future
of data science
and data scientists with every passing
year data science is improving and
expanding
at a significantly faster pace data
science has found its applications in
almost
every industry healthcare companies are
using data science to build
sophisticated medical instruments to
detect
and cure diseases video and computer
games are now being created with data
science
and that has taken the gaming experience
to the next level
similarly data science has taken various
other fields to a whole new level
the top three most common search terms
in july 2020
are data science machine learning and
artificial intelligence
according to the 2020 emerging jobs
report
linkedin listed data scientist as the
top third
job with an annual growth rate of 37
percent
for four years in a row data scientist
has been named the number one job in the
u.s by glassdoor
pursuing a career in data science is a
smart move
not just because it pays well and is
trendy
it is because data is the pivot point on
which
the entire economy turns
however you can also go to our video on
the topic
tips for becoming a data scientist for
more information
we'll link the video on the top right
corner for you to access quickly
also if you want to master data science
you can always go through simply learns
course
on data science and excel in this field
with that we've reached the end of
today's topic
thank you for watching the video and
stay tuned for more from simply learn
you